are you just about finished with Zelda
breath of the wild and looking for the
next game you'll play on your switch
well there are five new games on the
console this week and I'm going to run
you through them I'm Matt this is a game
spot news update and make sure to LIKE
and subscribe if you want to know about
all the latest games as they become
available The Binding of Isaac
afterbirth plus was originally supposed
to launch with the switch but after a
short delay it arrives on March
seventeenth for forty dollars if you
think that sounds a little expensive
it's important to remember that it
includes the base game and both of its
expansions the other four games include
king of fighters 94 little inferno human
resource machine and World of Goo king
of fighters 94 is eight dollars while
the other three costs ten dollars each
the Nintendo switch has been out for
almost two weeks now and it's got itself
a good library of games we've even given
favorable reviews to breath of the wild
fast rmx snipper clips and more you can
read those on gamespot com but if you
want to watch a switch game check out
our video on the Easter eggs that you
definitely missed in breadth of the wild
[Music]
you